salut brut c'est kenny j'ai 25 ans je
suis youtuber et je me lance dans le
plus gros projet de ma vie le projet
d'une perte de poids je dois perdre 150
kg venez avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusque là j'ai mon frigo qui est vide
depuis le commencement de ma perte de
poids forcément y'a pus
la transition elle était compliqué
surtout que ma femme elle est toute
petite toute fine donc elle elle peut se
permettre de taper dans du nutella - non
je mange des kiwis parce que ça c'est
super acide super sucre est super bon je
mange un porridge avec flocons d'avoine
et lait d'amande et je vais me faire
aussi une petite home est juste après
pour bâle côté protéines exceptions
c'est interdit dans la loin ce que je
mange avant c'était des débats et de
tartines de nutella de de plusieurs bol
de céréales
plains vraiment au petit déjeuner je
bombarde et je me faisais plein donc
voilà le le petit résultat final et là
je vais dégoût stade tout ça c'est trop
à cela
là on est sur mon set up donc cette
oeuvre qui qui a tant souffert
parce que j'en ai passé des heures et
c'est un l'époque un micro c'est kenny
j'espère que vous avez bien manger en
tout cas nous on n'a pas mangé
bonheur c'était le pc et je passais
vraiment
sur 24 heures un bon 18h sur l'ordi est
ce que vous êtes ready les gars pas wow
ça fait tout bizarre groupe c'était
vraiment dormir pc dormir pc j'ai
vraiment une phase où je ne l'avais pas
tous les jours et où c'était une vie de
malade et je me suis entre guillemets
engraisser sans le voir parce que la
seule chose que je vois c'est un écran
j'espère que vous allez bien j'espère
que vous avez bien manger moi je vais
manger là un maxi bergen est toujours
dit depuis que je me suis marré avec ma
femme c'est le jour où cheminée donc
voila depuis je n'ai rencontré que je
fais beaucoup plus d'efforts je prenais
beaucoup plus soin de moi et tous et
c'est là que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai
commencé à prendre en main à penser et
tout se marrait bien réussir à perdre du
poids avant que mes parents qui
commencent à vieillir par mais le plus
important c'est moi c'est ma santé mon
bien-être mes déplacements métrage et je
remarque dans le train que je prends une
place et demi que noël toilettes du
train je passe pas et je sors de cette
zone de confort et je m'en rends compte
de tout en fait
c'est parti pour une heure de séance à
l'ego les choses
est ce qu'ils ont en main
c'est bon première chose qui nous ce qui
me passait à l'esprit c'est ouais je
fais tes dégâts je vais t'aider à bosser
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose qui motive énormément
énormément c'est la haine en fait vu que
sur youtube j'ai forcément des milliers
de commentaires et des milliers de
messages de haine des milliers des
noeuds de hauteur et hausse trop facile
de tailler les gros il ya trop de blacks
sur les gros quand tu quand tu pèses ya
ton numéro qui s'affiche quand tu tombes
du lit tu tombes des deux côtés il ya
trop trop de trucs et c'est vraiment
pourquoi j'ai utilisé l'auto dérision
pour me vanner avant de me faire vanner
et pourquoi pourquoi je veux perdre du
poids juste pour ne plus me faire vanner
ne plus avoir à neuf années en fait une
des mes plus grosse motivation c'est
vraiment way une vengeance sur la vie
je me suis déjà excusé d'être comme
chute d'être gros parce que je prends tu
repasses parce que je touche quelqu'un
ou parce que si ou parce que ça perd du
poids ça va pour tous pour nous par
rapport à ma femme de voyage ensemble
qu'on prenne le train comprennent avions
par rapport à ma famille par rapport à
ma vie pour avoir la société par rapport
au vert par rapport à un milliard de
trucs ça va être mieux en fait le
meilleur conseil que je peux donner
c'est de ne rien lâcher de croire vous
de foncer et de devenir une meilleure
version soi même simplement
[Musique]